Traductor: Paula Grisel Naish
Revisor: Denise RQ
[¿Cómo se volvió Drácula
el vampiro más famoso del mundo?]
Después de más 100 años
de la muerte de su creador,
Drácula sigue siendo ser el vampiro
más famoso de la historia.
Pero este noble transilvano
no fue el primer vampiro
ni el más popular de su época
y podría haber quedado olvidado
de no ser por un giro del destino.
La primera aparición de Drácula fue
en la novela de Bram Stoker en 1897.
Pero eso fue mucho después de la
aparición de los mitos de vampiros.
Ya había monstruos chupa-sangre
unos 800 años antes de esta fecha.
Fue la cultura eslava la que
nos dio la palabra vampiro,
o "upir" en ruso antiguo.
La primera mención escrita del
término se hizo en el siglo XI.
La cultura de vampiros de la región
precedió al cristianismo
y persistió a pesar del esfuerzo de
la iglesia por eliminar cultos paganos.
Las historias de vampiros se originaron
en la interpretación errónea de muertes
por rabia, por pelagra,
y por la descomposición.
En este último caso, los gases hinchaban
el cuerpo y la sangre salía por la boca
lo que hacían a un cuerpo parecer
que hubiera estado vivo
y comiendo recientemente.
Los vampiros se describían como hinchados,
con dientes y uñas largos de más.
Esto dio lugar a muchos rituales
para prevenir que los muertos se levasen,
como enterrarlos con ajo
o semillas de amapola,
y también estacarlos,
quemarlos o mutilarlos.
La tradición del vampirismo siguió
siendo común hasta el siglo XVIII
cuando Serbia se encontró
entre dos grandes poderes,
la monarquía de los Habsburgo
y el imperio Otomano.
Soldados austriacos y empleados estatales
observaron y documentaron
los extraños rituales locales de entierro,
y sus reportes se difundieron enormemente.
La histeria resultante por el vampirismo
se descontroló tanto que en 1755,
la emperatriz austriaca debió
darle la tarea a su médico personal.
Él investigó y puso fin a los rumores
publicando una refutación
científica muy exhaustiva.
El pánico se apaciguó, pero
el vampiro ya había calado hondo
en la imaginación de la Europa occidental,
creando obras como "El vampiro" en 1819,
y "Carmilla" de Joseph Sheridan
Le Fanu en 1872.
Este último libro influyó enormemente
un joven irlandés llamado Bram Stoker.
Stoker, quien nació en Dublín en 1847,
sufrió de una enfermedad desconocida
que lo tuvo postrado hasta los siete años.
Durante ese tiempo,
su madre le leyó cuentos tradicionales
y verdaderas historias de terror.
Incluidas sus propias experiencias
durante el brote de cólera del 1832.
Allí, le describió a las víctimas
enterradas vivas en fosas comunes.
Más tarde en su vida, Stoker escribió
historias de fantasía, romance y aventura,
y en 1897: "Drácula".
Aunque el villano del libro
con el mismo nombre
se cree basado en la histórica figura
de Vlad III Drácula, o Vlad el Empalador,
y la asociación se debe
en mayor parte solo al nombre.
Los demás elementos y personajes
fueron inspirados directa e indirectamente
por muchas obras de la época victoriana
como "El misterioso extraño".
La novela tuvo un éxito
moderado en su estreno
y no fue uno de las obras
más conocidas de Stoker,
siendo mencionada brevemente
en su obituario de 1912.
Pero la lucha por los derechos de autor
cambiaría drásticamente
el destino de Drácula
y lo catapultaría al renombre literario.
En 1922, un estudio alemán
adaptó la novela al cine
con "Nosferatu", la clásica película
muda, sin pagar regalías.
A pesar de cambiar los nombres
y algunos puntos del argumento,
los paralelos era evidentes
y luego del juicio el estudio quebró.
Para prevenir más intentos de plagio,
la viuda de Stoker decidió
brindar los derechos de autor
a la versión teatral de "Drácula",
aprobando la producción de la obra por
un amigo de la familia, Hamilton Deane.
Aunque la adaptación de Deane
le hizo cortes drásticos a la historia,
se volvió un clásico
gracias principalmente a la actuación
de Bela Lugosi en Broadway.
Lugosi también actuó para Universal
en la versión cinematográfica de 1931,
dándole al personaje muchas
de sus características propias.
A partir de ese momento, Drácula
ha sido adaptado incontables veces,
encontrando la vida eterna más allá
de las humildes páginas de su nacimiento.